I'm sitting here with Jacques one of our
lead front-end engineers do you like
tofu I did well well prepared tofu well
prepared what does that mean to you ah
there's a whole spectrum of sort of the
preparations of tote of tofu and I'm
about like a hunk of tofu from costco or
something just a raw hunk of tofu yeah
probably not the most delicious okay why
uh it there are so many things you could
do with it that would add additional
flavors to your to your tofu okay so
there's a saying that I heard well
actually I made it up it's called be
tofu and to me it applies as well to
code do you have any idea what I'm
talking about not really all right so
here's what I mean by that tofu to me is
pretty bland it's fairly uninteresting
it doesn't really have a flavor of its
own I mean it does but not really so
when some if I get dropped into a code
base what I want to do as a programmer
is I want to be tofu I want to look
around me and just absorb and seep in
the flavors around me or the culture
right the way that the people wrote the
code i want to write mine just like that
for consistency so if they're using
jquery i'm going to use jquery if
they're not using jquery i'm not going
to use jquery if they don't put
semicolons well i'll be really unhappy
about it but I hope do that to note
always use semicolons always so can you
tell me an example of maybe when that
may have happened to you yeah dropped
into a code base and it wasn't exactly
the way you would have written it but
yeah absolutely um when I first joined
Udacity it was on launch weekend and
there was already some code going and
once the code is rolling you especially
when you're trying to get stuff done on
a deadline and there's not really a good
place to say hey we might be able to do
this better sticking with that culture
means that at least your code is
consistent and what that means is that
once you get the accent of the code down
and you will from working in it from
from experiencing it and coding around
in it it's much easier to understand the
code
bass as a whole that consistency is very
important so it's basically really
important to have your one codebase have
one single accent for consistency yeah
absolutely because one you start working
with the code if you have to shift your
mental model about how this is written
every time you open up a file or within
a file say from line to line it's really
hard and so that's why having that that
consistency will at least let you once
you know what the sort of the local
dialect is you you can speak in that you
can write in that you can read in that
consistently and you don't have to spend
all of the overhead shifting your mental
model around about how this code is
written you know what this means so it
seems like this is being polite to other
coders that come along yeah absolutely
an end to yourself I mean it's going
future you is going to come back to this
code and go why are there why do half of
these lines have semicolons so you want
future you to not hate past you which is
apparently present you exactly and
that's like a huge part of being a good
engineer is not getting future you angry
at present you it's really hard you
don't always do it but that's absolutely
the goal awesome so consistency within a
code base even if it's not necessarily
your specific style it's really
important and ultimately thanks doctor
said no with me definitely remember kids
always use tabs